[Music]
the moment the first baggage detachments
of our army was seen by the enemy who
were lurking hidden in the woods they
suddenly dashed forth in full force
having already in the woods ordered
their line in regular ranks and
encouraged one another for the conflict
and so charged down upon our cavalry our
cavalry were easily beaten and thrown
into disorder and with incredible speed
the enemy rushed down to the river so
that almost at the same moment they were
seen at the edge of the woods in the
river and then at close quarters
i had everything to do at one moment the
flag to raise a signal of a general call
to arms the trumpet call to sound the
troops to recall from entrenching the
men to bring in who had gone somewhat
farther afield the line to form the
troops to harangue the signal to give
a great part of these duties was
prevented by the shortness of time and
the advance of the enemy i gave the
necessary commands and then ran down in
a chart's direction to harangue the
troops and came to the 10th legion my
harangue to the troops was no more than
a charge to bear in mind their ancient
valor to be free from alarm and bravely
to withstand the onslaught of the enemy
then as the enemy were no further off
than the range of a missile i gave the
signal to engage i started off in the
other direction to give the same
harangue but found them already fighting
the men of the 12th legion with their
standards collected in one place were so
closely packed in that they hampered
each other for fighting all the
centurions of the fourth cohort had been
slain and the standard bearer likewise
and the standard was lost the condition
of affairs as i saw was critical indeed
and there was no support that could be
sent up taking therefore a shield from a
soldier of the rearmost ranks as i
myself was coming thither without a
shield i went forward into the first
line and calling on the centurions by
name and cheering on the rank and file i
paid them advance and extend the
companies that they might ply swords
more easily my coming brought hope to
the troops and renewed their spirit each
man of his own accord in sight of their
commander-in-chief desperate as his own
cause might be was fain to do his utmost
so the onslaught of the enemy was
checked a little i instructed the
tribunes to close the legions gradually
together and then to advance against the
enemy this was done and as one soldier
supported another and they did not fear
that their rear would be surrounded by
the enemy they began to resist more
boldly and to fight more bravely
meanwhile the soldiers of the two
legions which had acted as baggage guard
at the rear of the column heard news of
the action pressing on with all speed
they became visible to the enemy on the
crest of the hill their arrival wrought
a great change in the situation even
such of our troops as had fallen under
stress of wounds propped themselves
against their shields and renewed the
fight then the subtlers seeing the panic
of the enemy met their armed assault
even without arms finally the cavalry to
obliterate by valor the disgrace of
their flight fought at every point in
the effort to surpass the legionaries
the enemy however even when their hope
of safety was at an end displayed a
prodigious courage when their front
ranks had fallen the next stood on the
prostrate forms and fought from them
when these were cast down and the
corpses were piled up in heaps the
soldiers standing as if it were upon a
mound hurled darts on our troops or
court and returned our pikes not without
reason therefore was it to be concluded
that these were men of great courage who
had dared to cross a very broad river to
climb very high banks and to press up
over most unfavorable ground these were
tasks of the utmost difficulty but
greatness of courage had made them easy
but finally the engagement brought the
name and the nation of the nervy eye
almost
to utter
destruction
polybius tells us that the romans would
use new passwords or watch words every
night are you as careful as the romans a
lot of people just log into everything
using their facebook account but what
would happen if that was hacked or if
someone discovered your simple password
you use for everything well nordpass is
ideal to help it's a simple secure easy
to use password manager from the guys
behind nordvpn and is the sponsor for
this video it'll help you store all your
passwords in one place generate secure
passwords for you and autofill to save
time they can also tell you if your data
has appeared in a data breach and if you
are at risk of being hacked the usa has
on average five password leaks per
person follow this link for an exclusive
discount for a two-year nordpass premium
account at nordpass.com forward slash
votp or use the code votp and you'll get
a free month too thanks to nordpass for
supporting history content on youtube
i and my knights had decided to go and
attack some turks who were loading their
baggage and their camp on our left so we
fell on them as we were pursuing them
through the camp i caught sight of a
saracen on the point of mounting his
horse one of his knights was holding the
bridle at the moment he had both of his
hands on the saddle to pull himself up i
gave him a thrust with my lance just
under the armpit and struck him dead on
seeing this his knight left his lord and
the horse and thrusting his lance at me
as i passed caught me between the
shoulders pinning me down to the neck of
my horse in such a way that i couldn't
draw the sword at my belt i therefore
had to draw the sword attached to my
horse when he saw me with my sword drawn
he withdrew his lance and left
as i was coming back the turks thrust at
me with their lances under the weight of
their attack my horse was brought to its
knees and i went flying forward over its
ears i got up as soon as i could with my
shield at my neck and sword in hand one
of my knights named error deceivery may
god grant him grace came to me and
advised our drawing back towards a
ruined house where we could wait for the
king who was on his way but as we were
going there some on foot and someone
horseback a great body of turks came
rushing at us bearing me to the ground
and riding over my body so that my
shield went flying from my neck
as soon as they had passed error
deceivery came back to me and took me
with him to the walls of the house while
we were there the turks attacked us from
all sides some of them got into the
house and pricked us with their lances
from above my knights asked me to hold
on to their horse's bridles which i did
for fear the beasts should run away then
they put up a vigorous defense against
the turks during this incident hugh
dakot received three wounds in the face
from alliance and so did raul dawanu
de lupe had a large thrust between his
shoulders which made so large a wound
that the blood poured from his body as
if from the bung hole of a barrel
a blow from one of the enemy's swords
landed in the middle of error deceiver's
face cutting through his nose so that it
was left dangling over his lips
just as i had uttered a prayer he said
to me my lord if you think that neither
i nor my heirs will incur reproach for
it i will go and fetch you help from the
conta andrew whom i see in the fields
over there
i said to him my dear man it seems to me
that you would win great honor for
yourself if you went for help to save
our lives your own by the way is also in
great danger i spoke truly for he died
of his wound
as i stood there on foot with my knights
wounded as i have told you king louis
came up at the head of his battalion
with a great sound of shouting trumpets
and kettle drums he halted with his
troops on a raised causeway
never have i seen a finer or more
handsome night he seemed to tower head
and shoulders above all his people on
his head was a gilded helmet and a sword
of german steel was in his hand
the moment he stopped those good knights
in his division whom i have already
named to you together with other valiant
knights of his flung themselves right at
the turks
it was i can assure you a truly noble
passage of arms for no one there drew
either bow or crossbow it was a battle
of maces against swords between the
turks and our people with both sides
inextricably entangled
[Music]
looking at it the city of yunnan foo
appeared strong and impregnable the
field marshal withdrew the troops and
retreated to a distance of seven lee
from the city we set up our encampment
along the mountainside and received
orders to make ramparts and moats during
the night
i the head of the regiment's soldiers
worked overnight erecting ramparts and
digging moats
the first squadron advanced to cut off
the tail of the bandits and to seek an
opening towards the city but when our
green standard troops charged the enemy
the roaring sound of cannons and muskets
was incessant and lasted for such a long
time that the ears became used to it
half of the rebels vacillated and fled
but the other half comprising several
squadrons did not budge and were
resolved to fight to the death
councillor hefei called aloud and
ordered crush those rebel detachments
that have not been routed and are still
in control of the bridge in the village
our two banners yelling went to the
assault but the enemy's fire of cannons
fiery arrows and the volleys of muskets
were overwhelming protecting themselves
in hidden spots among the ruined walls
our two banners became all mingled into
one group i reached the bank of the
river by myself and saw that our
soldiers were being continuously wounded
hefe sent a man with the order to
advance on foot and as soon as we got
within shooting range the rear guard of
the rebels was in disarray i immediately
grabbed the flag and crossed the river
pressing forward in pursuit of the
rebels rearguard
the rebels fled as soon as i caught up
with them i told them that they must all
surrender they all knelt down lay down
their weapons and begged me to spare
their lives
[Music]
then when a bearer guard shot a rebel
with an arrow they all stood up and fled
two rebels got hold of long swords that
had been abandoned and indifferent to
death came forward slashing at us
rushing off i whipped the horse and
climbed on top of the high riverbank
looking behind me i saw that armoured
soldier dengsei could not climb onto the
bank one rebel caught up with him and
hacked at him because dengsei was scared
he ducked turned his body on one side so
the rebel hit the quiver and the horse
as deng say fell off the horse i shot
the rebel and made him fall down who
killed the other rebel i do not know i
looked to make sure that dengsei had not
been harmed then quickly got hold of my
flag and pushing and killing reached the
base of the city wall one could see that
the rebels at the base of the wall were
ready for battle
thickly lined up in a two echelon
formation they were also firing cannons
from the top of the wall
as our soldiers heard the bugle signal
for the withdrawal of the troops they
immediately turned back altogether
then we interrogated captured rebels
on the 12th the emperor in person
arrived from beijing at the head of the
chief ministers in a wide open space he
pitched the palatial square tent and
greeted the field marshal high officials
officers and soldiers he lined up the
flags and prostrated in front of the
flags at the sound of the conch
thereupon he ordered generals and
soldiers to present themselves kneeling
down in front of him and offered them
tea everyone prostrated in front of his
imperial grace
i went to lugow bridge and kneeling down
met my father i heard about the matter
concerning my fourth brother
then weeping i went through the gardens
entered the city and still weeping
entered my house
i prostrated as i met my mother and the
others when i met my children and
younger brothers
i could not recognize them
looking at them the houses and heated
beds of the capital appeared even more
odd and suddenly it was like a confused
hazy dream
the more i thought about it the more i
marveled at what seemed like being born
again
is this a dream
or is it not
[Music]
as our small and way-worn party came to
a halt before the walls of the convent
the men from these different regiments
came swarming out to greet us loudly
cheering us as they rushed up and seized
our hands the difference in appearance
between ourselves and these newcomers
was indeed just then very great
they looked fresh from good quarters and
good rations their clothes and
accoutrements were comparatively new and
clean and their cheeks ruddy with the
glow of health and strength whilst our
men on the contrary were gaunt looking
way worn and ragged our faces burnt
almost to the hue of an asiatics by the
sun our accoutrements rent and torn and
many without even shoes to their feet
however we had some work in us yet and
perhaps we're in better condition for it
than our more fresh-looking comrades
war is a sad blunter of the feelings of
men
we felt eager to be at it again
now i'm afraid we longed for blood as
the cheer of our comrades sounded in our
ears
and yet amidst all this
softer feelings occasionally filled the
breasts of these gallant fellows
even whilst they were thirsting for a
sight of the enemy
some of the men near me suddenly
recollected as they saw the snow lying
thickly in our path that this
was christmas eve
the recollection soon spread amongst the
men and many talked of home and scenes
upon that night in other days in old
england
shedding tears as they spoke of their
relatives and friends never to be seen
by them again
as the night approached we became less
talkative when suddenly a shout arose in
front that the french were upon us in an
instant every man was on the alert and
we were rushing forwards in extended
order to oppose them and proved a false
alarm
thus we staggered on night and day for
about four days before we discovered the
reason of this continued forced march
the discovery was made by a good
tempered jolly fellow named patrick
mclaughlin he inquired of an officer
marching directly in his front the
destination intended by jesus muster
hills i heard him say where the dickens
is it you're taking us to to england
mclaughlin returned the officer with a
melancholy smile on his face
if we can get there
this mclaughlin was a good specimen of a
thorough irish soldier nothing could
disturb his good humor and high spirits
he'd ever sum piece of irish humor upon
his tongue's end whilst he staggered
under the weight of his pack he would in
all probability have been amongst the
first who did reach england but during
the march he was attacked with the
wracking pains of acute rheumatism and
frequently fell to the ground screaming
with agony
on such occasions his companions would
do that for him which they admitted to
perform towards others whilst the men
could scarcely refrain from laughter the
extraordinary things he gave utterance
to when wrecked with pain
and staggering with fatigue at length
however mclaughlin fell one dark night
as we hurried through the streets of a
village and we could not again raise him
it's no use harris i heard him say in a
faint voice
i can do no more
next morning when day broke he was no
longer seen in the ranks and as i never
saw him again i conclude he quickly
perished
crawford seemed to sniff the sound of
battle from afar with peculiar feelings
he halted us for a few minutes
occasionally when the distant clamour
became more distinct and his face turned
towards the sound and seemed to light up
and become less stern it was then indeed
that every poor fellow clutched his
weapon more firmly and wished for sight
of the enemy
before long they had their wish the
enemy's cavalry were on our skirts that
night and as we rushed out of a small
village the name of which i cannot now
recollect we turned to bay behind broken
down carts huge trunks of trees and
everything we could scrape together the
rifles lay and blazed away at the
advancing cavalry once the inhabitants
suddenly aroused from their beds to
behold their village almost on fire
without continued discharges ran from
their houses the rain was pouring down
in torrance on this morning i recollect
and we remained many hours with our arms
ready standing in this manner staring
the french cavalry in the face the water
actually running out of the muzzles of
our rifles
a man named higgins was my front rank
man at this moment harris said he let
you and i gained the very top of this
mountain and look out what those french
thieves are doing at the other side
my feet were sore and bleeding and the
sinews of my legs ached as if they would
burst but i resolved to accompany him
but one or two of the videts of the
french cavalry were prowling around very
near where we went as we had received
orders not to make more noise than we
could help not even to speak to each
other except in whispers
although one of these horsemen
approached close to where i lay i
forebore to fire against him
at length he stopped so near me that i
saw it was almost impossible he could
avoid discovering that the rifles were
in such close proximity to his person
he gazed cautiously along the ridge took
off his helmet and wiped his face
when suddenly our eyes met
and in an instant he plucked a pistol
from his holster fired in my face and
wheeling his horse plunged down the
hillside for the moment i thought i was
hit but the ball grazed my neck and
stuck fast in my knapsack where i found
it when many days afterwards i unpacked
my kit aboard ship
i remember the first occasion when i was
called upon to go over the top it was
during the somm do where our battalion
had already been in some nasty business
i heard about the third company's
experiences during my recovery from an
overdose of rum and i was new enough a
soldier to feel the strain on my heart
strings when i realized that rum stupa
had saved me from participation the date
was july 27 1916
we were bivouacked in a valley near
flickr a place of vast mine craters in
virgin chalk
i remember clambering about them trying
to stop my imagination from recreating
the sensations of the troops with once
occupied trenches there lying about were
bits of equipment clothing
bodies
god imagination was not needed the thing
was reconstructed before my eyes
i was in this frame of mind when we were
told to be prepared to move into the
line that night
i was a signaler most old soldiers will
know what this implies bayonet drill
bombing practice in short all those
exercises which were supposed to make an
efficient soldier had been carefully and
cunningly dodged i began to regret this
already i could see myself outclassed by
some proficient german in a hand-to-hand
encounter to be sure the blade of his
bayonet would be sore cut good lord what
a fool i had been i wondered what it
might feel like to be wounded
to be killed
all through that night i never had a
wink of sleep in the morning we were
told that our affair had been postponed
24 hours our co kept us from a sleep of
exhaustion which is so easy in the
morning by choosing that time for his
heroic lecture to us in whose hands lay
his reputation
slowly but surely that day the 28th
past last night we thought we were going
over the top tonight we know how co
himself told us so
back come all the bogeys of the previous
night i find myself engaged in
calculating the chances of escape surely
a quarter of our number will remain
unscathed i have one chance in four of
coming out none the worse
and so i tortured myself all through
that second night
at times i would not off to sleep
it's all off it's all off something
would say and my whirling maddening
thoughts becoming smoother less
insistent more incoherent would creep
almost into the arms of sleep
fool wake up it's postponed one hour two
hours that's all i jumped with a start
the whole mental anguish began all over
again
we did not go up that night
but on the night of the 29th we actually
started for the front line where we had
been lying in bivouac the noise of the
guns had been an incessant thunder we'd
found time to pity the poor devils who
were already in the thick of it now we
found ourselves approaching the monster
gradually as we moved we were enrabbed
in that almost sea of sound and shells
burst nearer and nearer
stumbling along in the inky darkness the
intensity of which was preserved by
frequent explosions i can hardly attempt
to describe my thoughts and feelings
there came a time when two horses dashed
madly past us towards the rear they had
been released from their load by a shell
which had killed their driver and
shattered their wagon with a crash one
of them collapsed within a yard of us
showing horribly plainly that even horse
flesh could not be disemboweled and live
we continued going forward
then the darkness was temporarily
relieved a dump of very lights had been
exploded and a firework display enough
to confuse the most carefully contrived
artillery signals share the fantastic
light upon this hell on earth
darkness may be awful but when duty
tells you to go and be killed and in the
going to walk past wounded men right and
left in the eerie light of military
fireworks the horror of it becomes
almost unbearable just before we arrived
in our jumping off trench something
happened which i can never forget a
young soldier of my own section was
struck by a shell fragment square
between the eyes
his cries haunt me now
mother of god mother of god he shrieked
time and time again
we left him behind where he lay
whimpering mother of god good god i'm
blind
he got in my ears
mother of god i reiterated
scarcely knowing what i was saying
at last we arrived at the front line
zero was 7 15 am in a few minutes we
would endure the supreme test
furtive peeps over the parapet revealed
nothing of the enemy trenches for a mist
lay overall
in me strangely enough this induced
feelings of utter weariness followed by
spasms of fatalistic carelessness which
i could have wished to last the whole
war through
but our emotions come and go like clouds
in the sky and my new found peace of
mind was short-lived
suddenly the noise of the guns eased off
for a second or two there was quiet
then
the fury of our barrage dropped like a
wall of roaring sound before us by some
means the signal to advance was given
and understood and we found ourselves
walking forward in the mist feeling
utterly naked who can express the
sensations of men brought up in trench
warfare suddenly divested of every scrap
of shelter
forward we stumbled into a mist that
seemed to grow ever thicker so great was
the noise that the order to keep in
touch with one another was passed only
by means of shouting our hardest and our
voices sounded like flutes in a vast
orchestra of fiends
all at once i became conscious of
another sound a noise like the crisp
crackle of twigs and branches burning in
a bonfire just beyond my vision in the
mist made me think i must be approaching
some burning building
but i realized when my neighbor on the
right dropped with a bullet in the
abdomen that the noise was machine gun
and rifle fire presently we came to the
first enemy trench when we saw our
artillery had done its work well and
truly we had to pass this trench but
there was almost no need to jump over it
for it was almost filled in
blown in
after scrambling over what remained of
this trench i found myself with another
signal cut off completely from the rest
by the mist we had come close together
in our scrambling and remained together
we were alone in a mist which we began
to suspect was not all together made by
nature
here was a fine mess
friar that was my companion's name and
myself cut off from our comrades not
knowing whether we were going nor how
far we should go
what should we do we did what
irresponsible private soldiers could do
dropped into the nearest shell hole
discussing our position over a woodbine
we went to sleep
an hour later i was nudged into
wakefulness by friar it was considerably
quieter but bullets were still zipping
past the mist had cleared a little and
visibility was extended to about 400 or
500 yards it was with real thankfulness
that i found the captain of our company
he was sheltering in a shell hole just
as friar and i had done
messages had already gone out we were
told ordering a general withdrawal to
our starting point
the attack had failed
pray god we should not have to do it all
over again
i'm sorry i cannot finish this short
account of a push with some stirring
deed of valor
fritz soon became aware of our intention
to abandon the attack and it was not
long before his artillery was blowing
our trench to pieces friar was killed at
my side i cannot describe the incident
i saw about as much red as was left in
the poor chap's face when he settled in
a crouching posture
dead
from that time until we were relieved i
waited every second for a similar end i
was buried and got out i trembled
violently for ten solid minutes with
shell shock which recovered and had to
hang on our whole brigade had suffered
very heavy losses we were taken behind
the lines for arrest addressed by our
goc told how through lack of information
we had valiantly attacked a force three
times our number and after being brought
up to strength we were sent in to do it
again